so he's here
and a guy can really control
what you're doing okay but he can anchor
his elbow here
and anchor someone here and i control so
he tries to posture
and he can't posture and eventually like
he finds
things okay and so
it's not so easy uh
to always get this off okay
so look at what i'm what i'm doing here
i'm trapped inside his head
and his grip and his anchored elbow okay
so i i don't want to go against that
because that's going to be yong
on yong okay so i'm gonna go
this way maybe my hand helps me
this one then my other hand
goes in and i use two hands
so you just peel that off
then i want to start the spiral okay
so if he's pushing then i'm going to
turn this
okay if he's pulling going this way
go back if he's pulling this way
then i'll enter and i'll pull this way
but i'm now on the outside
so he's pushing hook
he's pulling i go in with it and i'm on
the outside
he pushes
he falls
pushes out
okay your basic aikido strategy
is as as he goes he
just comes in i would move off so that
he has to now turn
to continue re-engaging so if i'm
if i'm on the inside he goes i will move
on
and he has to turn to keep engaging
so when i'm here like that he goes to
push
and he has to turn to keep engaging
so you don't go he goes
and now we're here he gets to come in
straight
he goes
it doesn't have to be a big turn in fact
if it's too big you give him the option
of spinning
okay so you just got to get off of this
center line
you just gotta get off of this center
line boom and now he has to turn
i just need him to want to turn
so i do have a escape but i have to put
it in with the
strategy okay
i'm not wrestling him with bob wrestling
so i'm not doing these
things so as as he pushes
that's what allows me to find a yield
okay so the same thing as he pulls
that's what allows me to get out i i am
in some sort of muscle match
and the idea is to get out of it so as
he goes
and i'm not
he
foreign same thing i'm getting out of
my contrast station
go go slow so you can see a little
slower please
he goes i yield i'm out he's going to
turn
from over here he's going to turn
i'm going to pass the arm this way and
then come up
boom push out he's gonna turn past the
arms
okay
so i have to make this arm go
this way
he's not running past me
his arm is getting dry boom
[Music]
okay you can only get as sharp as your
case so if your
sucks then
[Music]
then i can't get good at this okay so he
he's anchoring he's driving my center
he's totally manipulating me okay
and so as as he goes i can make my roof
smaller and then
more marshall okay i don't have to have
a in these big moves because you're not
going to be able to do that and i don't
need to do it if i
if i have these hidden releasing skills
i'm out
[Music]
and then as he hits the first void he
doesn't go unconscious he still
he has to come in
so my arm drag he's going to be pulling
him my arm drag is him pushing and i
move out of the way again
so my my move is pretty small
he's catching your heart
is
boom i'm out he comes to get me
but that's the energy that i need i'm
here i'm going to lower the arm
lower the arm start to check as he's
turning
then you're going to tighten
deviate
[Music]
can't go like this too much
we're asking too much
wait for him to come back
don't bring this arm back down so you
have to deal with any kind of
single leg or a double leg or anything
like that
i just needed that head to do that and
now
i use where i'm touching you see
i use where i'm touching to make you go
not much people are strong okay
so when i go here they're not gonna let
me open their arm over so i don't open
the arm all the way
you come at me and i turn that turn the
whole thing
turn this this whole thing this one you
see not
that lemon the whole thing turns
hey